this assessment task in complex numbers
covered a lot of different concepts
and skills and so we're going to go
through these questions one at a time
quickly if we can but we'll also we're
appropriate have a look at the multiple
strategies or different approaches to
each of the questions because sometimes
there are many different ways to solve
each question though i will stop along
the way and try and point out where i
think
one solution might be more elegant than
another
so here's the first question in multiple
choice it shows an argan diagram and
then you've got this number z that's
placed on it but
you don't know very much about z so it
might seem like it would be quite hard
to work out
if that's z where is as the question
asks
z squared on the modulus of z
now i will show you kind of like an
algebraic way to kind of handle what's
going
on here but before we get to that i
think it's more helpful to think
just in geometric terms right what do we
know about z
well we don't know how far away it is
from the origin you've got this dotted
line circle here but
you know you don't get given a radius
for that what you do know though
is this argument because if you have a
think about how far
you need to rotate around from the
positive real axis
to get to zed that pretty clearly looks
like i mean i'm only doing this
approximately but that's three quarters
of the way to a straight angle right so
that's three quarters
of pi now when you are multiplying a
complex number
by itself what happens is because you're
adding arguments
and multiplying moduli what happens is
you are going to get further or closer
away depending on
what the radius of that circle is but
more importantly for our purposes here
you're going to rotate
and because you've got an argument here
of 3 pi on 4
we know that we're going to add those
arguments together so you get 3.4
plus 3 pi on 4 which is going to be 3 pi
on 2. it's not a principal argument but
i don't need it to be a principal
argument to be able to tell
a b c and d which is the most plausible
option
you can see down here um b is going to
be the best option
because the argument to b you can see 3
pi on 2
rotating around like so so clearly even
without going any further
into a b c and d as the different
options b is clearly the best one
i will point out if you want to do this
again in a more sort of
algebraic way i can just define z to be
some some complex number with an unknown
modulus because remember i don't know
how big this circle is
but i know that the argument has to be
about three pi and four because you can
see where it sits
on the complex plane so when i go
through
and i square it this is what i get on
the numerator the modulus of z if we use
this
r e to the i theta notation the modulus
of z is just
r so you can see that's why i'm dividing
through r squared by r
leaving me with one r if you come back
to the diagram that's why
your options a b c and d they're all on
the circumference of that original
circle
and that three pi on two i got from
doubling this angle over here all right
so then question two which complex
number is a sixth root
of i now you can see over here i've
gotten an answer of a but before you get
to that answer
you can actually very rapidly exclude
some of the answers that
are nonsensical for instance the sixth
root of i
right so this is some number let's call
it say w
and when i raise it to the sixth power
i should get i now as we noted before
when you multiply complex numbers by
each other
there's going to be rotation but there's
also going to be scaling right
now if you have a number that is further
away from the origin then as you
multiply it
it scales up further and further and
further and so since i know that i
is actually on the unit circle that
tells me that these two options here c
and d
are immediately irrelevant because you
know root 2 is about
1.4 so this is negative 1.4 plus 1.4 i
so where would that be on an argan
diagram if i were to draw
a very rough icon diagram here and put
let's put a unit circle on here because
oh that's an ellipse that's not what i
wanted let's draw something a little
more circular so it recognizes that's
better
so if we place i here where would
negative 1.4
plus 1.4 i where would that sit 1.4 is
about that far
and that fast so i'm guessing it'll be
somewhere
up here now it's clearly too far away
when you multiply that even
by itself once right you're already away
from the unit circle
you're just going to get further and
further away so that's why i've
eliminated options
c and d and then to work out out of
options a
and b which one is better again i think
about the arguments that's the key
difference between them minus 1 and root
2 plus 1 of root 2 i
has the same modulus as minus 1 on root
2 minus
1 or root 2 i because and they just sit
in different quadrants
so that's why you can see over here i'm
really focusing on the angle
3 pi and 4 if you raise it to the sixth
power you're just multiplying that index
by 6. so 18 pi
4 becomes 9 pi on 2. 9 pi on 2 is an
enormous argument so i'm subtracting
integer multiples of 2 pi because that's
full revolution so this is
2 full revolutions that brings you back
to pi on 2
that's i which is what i wanted after
all so that's how i know
the answer is a and then here comes the
last multiple choice question so here's
this curve on the eigen diagram below
which equation defines this curve well
we know it's going to between be between
this point over here 4 and this point
over here
minus 2i so therefore remembering the
form of all different minor and major
arcs
we need something that's of the form
stay on red i guess
z minus 4 and also this is z
minus negative 2 i so that would be z
plus 2i so when you have a look you can
see again i can remove some options
fairly quickly because you've got these
z minus 2i
options over here c and d
and then you can see oh z minus 4. well
this is the case in both of them so now
i have to choose between a
and b uh what's the difference between a
and b well you've got the z minus fours
the same
the z plus two i's the same the pi on
three is the same for all of them
the difference is where's your start
point where's your end point so you can
see
i need to count uh measure my angles
anti-clockwise from a start point to an
end point
so is it anti-clockwise to go in
this direction or is it anti-clockwise
to go in
this direction and if you think
carefully about the direction that a
clock goes in
it's clearly going to be the blue
direction right so therefore get rid of
these red arrows
so i have to start from minus 2i then
i've got to go to 4
and that's why you can see i've written
anti-clockwise from negative 2i
to 4 and that's option b
so that's all the multiple choice
questions let's now dive into the
extended
response 4a starts with
some warm-up stuff here to be honest
just some simple straightforward complex
number arithmetic
so we defined for you a particular z and
a particular w
how do we square it well i won't go into
too much detail on this one because i
think you'll be okay
handling it you can see all i've done
here is this is just 7 plus 11i
and i've just expanded the brackets when
i square it
so there's my 7 squared there's my 11 i
squared noting that the i squared has
become a negative 1. and this is double
the product of these two so 77i is the
product of these two you double that
you get 154 i don't forget that
your complex numbers do have imaginary
parts so this is what you get
for z squared when you have a look at
part two you can see in my working i've
done this kind of
in two parts firstly i've said oh you
want z take away w
so that's what i started working out
over here so this is just my straight
substitution
and then i've collected like terms real
and imaginary parts
but then secondly i noticed the question
is also asking for the conjugate
of z minus w so that's me taking the
imaginary part and just
flipping the sign so that's part two and
then lastly for part three
you can see here is my division so
there's z
there's w and what i've multiplied
through by is the conjugate
of w because that gives me this uh
completing sorry not completing this
difference of squares down the bottom
that's just going to be completely real
so you get this 34 down there and that
eventually cancels out
with what neatly you have on the
numerator there which gives you
1 minus 2i as a final solution
okay part b now you have to be careful
with this one right because i think most
of us were okay to just start off as you
can see
here's my answer here that you're
multiplying out
on the left hand side you're expanding
these brackets and you're then saying oh
well once i expand it i'll get some real
bits
i'll get some imaginary bits and then
i'm going to equate them with what i
have over here
on the right hand side so you can see
i've already done that here in my
working
here's the first line of expansion and
then what i've done
is i have said this is real and
this is real so i've collected them over
here
and then this term or these this pair of
terms rather is imaginary so
i've factorized out the i and there's my
imaginary part there
so red part's going to be six blue parts
going to be seven so you'd get that
and you've got a pair of simultaneous
equations which you can then
solve like you have solve many sometimes
equations in the past
and then you get to this point uh maybe
you solved for
uh a instead of b it doesn't really
matter you can go in either order
but whichever order you go in you should
notice that when you get to this
factorization
as you would normally expect from a
quadratic equation alike
like this one right you get a pair of
solutions
but you have to read the question really
carefully and this is going to come back
as a theme again and again
our brains go so quickly into oh i'm
doing stuff i've got an algorithm in my
head that i'm really good
at but the question may actually have
told you additional information that you
needed
to be able to fine-tune or tweak your
algorithm accordingly so at this point
your algorithm normally tells you two
solutions b equals this b equals that
but the first line of the question
says a and b are integers so this tells
you when you get to this point
in the factorization just over here one
of these solutions
is not valid because b has to be an
integer
so you just get a single value for b and
that gives you a single value
for a so watch out for that one